on vient ici comme on irait au bar du
coin pour se rencontrer et papoter les
bains chauds 38 degrés minimum
c'est une tradition en islande et une
mise en jambe pour un marathon
frénétique
samedi il est léger à 23h les vannes
sont ouvertes pour déverser le stress de
la semaine 50 heures de travail en
moyenne pour un pays qui ne connaît pas
le chômage et dont le niveau de vie est
l'un des plus élevés d'europe
le jour et chauffer l'atmosphère 7° pas
un de plus dans un instant
c'est le couvre-feu la question pour les
enfants d'attendre que le soleil
vaciller que la lumière s'essouffle
et pour cause ce soir la nuit à oublier
de tomber il est minuit sur reykjavik
est épargné hier tous les tournois milk
connu cette époque bizarre non étonnant
pourtant ce soleil qui flirte avec
l'horizon et le caresse sans jamais se
laisser engloutir tout à fait il est
deux heures du matin comme tous les
week-ends les islandais 100 livres de
lumière mais aussi d'alcool fort noyer
la dépression chronique qui fait ici des
ravages
le seul moyen de n'être pas tout à fait
déboussolés par l'absence de saison
s'est agité sagittaire encore
on peut imaginer durant neuf mois de
l'année il fait un noir complet
absolument alors trois mois où il fait
jour tout le temps voyez on est comme
des fleurs on se réveille 3 heures du
matin à jeun ronflements sur la ville si
ce n'est celui des moteurs les grosses
cylindrées tournoi sans détour dire sans
but
tout plutôt que de rester chez soi
or quand même moins l'été que l'hiver on
profite du soleil n'est pas de voler
aucune maison n'a de volée renaissance
il est 4 heures du matin serait que la
vic le soleil est déjà haut dans le ciel
mais mi août ce sera fini alors
rapidement
l'islande sont mora dans l'hiver et dans
la nuit perpétuelle
non